[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday October
8th as you can no doubt tell puffed
levels are a little bit high
not even stressed out I just need a
haircut I mean seriously Hank my hair is
so puffy that if it's sampled a pop song
and used a bunch of lyrics by the
notorious b.i.g my hair could probably
become a platinum-selling rap artist
moving on Hank in your video on Friday
you talked about potential topics for
our feud and one of the topics you
discussed was the presidential election
of 2008 you are mostly for John Edwards
and I'm mostly for Barack Obama now Hank
I like John Edwards I think he's a bit
of a schmuck but I like him
I can vote for him I could happily vote
for him right now I happen to like
Barack Obama a little bit more but it's
early Hank I believe that politics are
important and the presidential politics
are particularly important in this
election cycle but I do think that smart
and thoughtful people can have honest
disagreements about presidential
politics which is why there are both
Republican nerdfighters and democratic
nerdfighters although Hank as it happens
I do have some questions for supporters
of Rudy Giuliani question one you want
Rudy Giuliani to be president question
two
seriously question three are you sure
question four you know he doesn't even
have the support of his kids right
question five Rudy Giuliani question six
as president question seven of the
United States of America question eight
really question nine are you sure
question 10 Rudy Giuliani huh
fascinating really anyway Hank is
important and interesting as it is to
have a vigorous discussion about
presidential politics which we've been
doing for months in my pants there's
something that I think matters just a
little bit more right now you prefer
unicorns the zombie's oh my god I don't
even know if you're my brother anymore
what on earth is there to like about
unicorns I know that you liked My Little
Ponies when you were a kid but I figured
you got over that and as offensive as I
find my little ponies and I find them
plenty of ffensive they're not nearly as
horrifying as those horned beasts of
suck Hank you probably don't know this
but young adult authors have been
feuding for months over the question of
whether or not Sam bees or unicorns are
preferable and I frankly cannot believe
that a member of my own family is on the
unicorn side now don't get me wrong Hank
there isn't much to recommend zambese I
mean
yes they inspired Shaun of the Dead
which yes was an excellent movie and of
course it's not like one of the best
noise metal bands ever was called white
unicorn but all that said Hank I don't
like zombies I mean they got flesh
hanging all over them they're not
technically people you put a zombie up
against a werewolf or a vampire I'm
gonna go against the zombie every time
but a unicorn Hank a unicorn
unicorns are like all the worst parts of
horses plus all the worst parts of
rhinoceri I mean seriously Hank and all
the fictional history what if unicorns
ever accomplished providing transport to
the Care Bears as they travel to and
from the forest of feelings Hank maybe
it's just me but I prefer the hard
truths of zombies to the easy lives of
unicorns and that goes for my presidents
as well as my myths Hank I hope you
didn't forget to be awesome this weekend
and I'll see you tomorrow although you
know what I could get behind maybe as a
compromise zombified unicorns